[Applause]
[Music]
you're happy because this this Russia
scandal is really heating up that
bussiness came out yesterday this is
pretty big [ __ ]
Trump ordered the Special Counsel
investigating Robert mode fired last
June just a couple of weeks after Muller
started his job and he only backed off
after the White House Counsel Don
McMahon said to him you know this isn't
a TV show right
listen did drubbs excuse why he thought
he could fire robert muller because
robert muller apparently used to be a
member at one of trumps golf courses and
he quit and Trump never gave him his
money back seriously so this is not over
Putin it's over putting that's what's
gonna bring down the government
first stormy Daniels now Muller is there
anyone Trump hasn't [ __ ] on a golf
course you know this is interesting
since Muller's investigation is largely
about whether Trump attempted to
obstruct justice now that includes
Trump's threats to fire Muller himself
so yes the man with the great brain the
stable genius who's like really really
smart has threatened the job of the guy
who was investigating him after firing
the last guy who investigated today Don
Jr said gee I thought I was supposed to
be the family [ __ ]
so this let this happen less that the
story breaks during Sean Hannity show
Hannity of course since it's bad for
Trump instinctively denies it a few
minutes later they actually report no
it's confirmed
so Hannity throws right away to a
high-speed chase and after the car
crashes the suspect gets out and he's
white
oh damn Sean some days you just can't
win huh buddy
[Applause]
but really I mean all over the
right-wing media they are all in on this
idea the Trump is not the perpetrator of
a crime he's the victim it's it's a
corrupt FBI hell-bent on taking down
Donald Trump it's the deep state people
Oh for [ __ ] sake it's the the deep
state is not going to bring down the
deep fryer might bring down you know
congressman Devin Nunez Republican
representing the district of Trump's :
he has a memo that he can't show anybody
but it's all in there everybody and rush
limbaugh oh my gosh rush limbaugh is so
in on this he said the CIA probably
faked the evidence of weapons of mass
destruction back in the Bush era to
trick Bush into invading Iraq and kids
that's why you should stay off the
opiates you know that stick with the pot
and maybe a beer now and then
now listen our country is such a
laughingstock now that Jeff sessions our
Attorney General is in Davos was they
just left with Trump the other day this
is Jeff Sessions tweet I'm not making
this up
he said other world leaders are clearly
treating him as an equal with respect as
one of them this is where the bar is now
for the American presidency other
leaders saw our leader and didn't point
in laughs hey let him sit at the table
and eat with them yeah Trump was in
Davos which one quick trip he got right
down to business he met with the head of
the African Union who was also the
president of Rwanda and charmed him boy
he offered to elevate Rwanda status to
most-favored [ __ ]
[Applause]
and Trump has a new immigration plan
have you heard this for the the dreamers
can stay if he gets twenty five billion
dollars for the wall which used to you
used to say would cost eight billion at
Mexico would pay for it but his
followers aren't stupid don't say that
no no no and it also came out that Trump
rejected the Democrats first offer to
fund the wall because he wanted to
preserve build the wall as a slogan in
2020 see the wall is kind of more
valuable to him as an idea than a
reality like his marriage love light may
have got out there you know it was their
anniversary this week their thirteenth
anniversary of course Trump said the
wrong thing he's with thirteen years
together I would buy you all over again
it's sadder than that actually they
didn't say anything
they've kept dinner no tweets back and
forth about that nothing and Milani was
supposed to go to Davos with him but at
the last minute didn't they said
scheduling and logistical reasons
yeah that's bureaucrat talk for why
don't you take the porn star you were
[ __ ]
[Applause]
Melania baby you got an itch us up a
[ __ ] head up della you know this is how
bad it is god I'm not kidding instead of
going to Davos with Donald Trump her
husband Melania went to the Holocaust
Museum to cheer up
she signed the guestbook
I know the feeling I mean
and she lit a candle to mourn the dark
day two weeks ago when Trump's doctor
said he was in good health and it was
off to lay a wreath on the tomb of the
unknown trophy wife but you know who's
not bad at donald trump for screwing a
porn star the event Jellicle did you see
this their head dude said we give him a
mulligan a mulligan one little blemish
on an otherwise spotless Christian life
I'm not sure Mulligan is what gets you
from trumps life to a life of a decent
human being I think the word for that is
reincarnation